anthony smith he's on food truck on
tuesday hopefully he doesn't lose here's
the thing fellas
i need anthony smith to get a win and
not get hurt okay we need anthony smith
to win this and not get hurt i like him
i like i like how tatted up he is well i
like his stance right now like he's got
a firm solid
stance but he knows nothing other guys
these daggers dude they are taking over
combat sports why do you why do you say
that well because it's probably tough no
they grow up there but they grow they
have their sport of combat they grow a
chuff they grow up doing it oh it's like
it's like three hundred yeah they grow
like spartans and they have [ __ ]
this is sparta five minutes later
anthony smith broke his ankle that's
what he said
was that with a little [ __ ] yeah
it can't be good for food oh [ __ ] yeah
bro stop being so selfish jesus
broke his ankle [ __ ] you can't come on
my youtube show
he does look like a show [ __ ] my
subscribers
you really let me down anthony yeah
my
brother was born and my and when my
brother was born you know how they say
like it's tough for the older like you
know sibling because like the attention
is now off
my grandpa got me a [ __ ] ram man
action figure
give to me the day my brother was born
so i could have something like to do and
i got the rayman action victor and
everyone's like oh cool that's ramen you
love ram man and i l and i was [ __ ]
three and a half and i said give it to
your brother he only no no that would be
the nice thing to do i said you only got
me this because he's here now i put it
down
they're all everything i mean how often
do you think a ram man zero times but
whenever i don't know that that's what i
think do you know who that is
he's a he-man
which one well i can't believe you think
okay you thought it was jim bring up a
brand man hey can we get matt a goddamn
cup for i'm gonna start typically
there's the 19 bros back there rand man
it is a [ __ ] festival bring some meat
where do you break
bring more meat